hello everybody and welcome to episode s
of my payto playay flipping Series where
we're going to go from Zer to 100 Mil
using the grand exchange only uh also
the membership we're going to renew only
with bonds um not just cuz I'm poor
which I am uh but just cuz I would like
to have a challenge and I think it makes
for a fun video so in today's episode we
still end up doing a lot more potion
flipping and now I thought about kind of
cutting through it quickly um because we
have done a couple episodes I've been
almost entirely focused on Flipping
these potions um this episode is pretty
much the last one near the end we start
doing some different things I thought
about cutting it out but it it's kind of
important to keep it in there because it
is more accurate that way this is a lot
of what flipping is you're going to run
some items to the ground as long as it's
working um you should keep doing it of
course I want to keep the videos
interesting so there's I'm trying to
balance the two between the most optimal
way to make money and trying to still
make for an interesting and entertaining
video so I'm kind of trying to
compromise here I I do the potion
sometimes and do some other items as
well um but this will be the last
hopefully last item episode that's
mainly focused on flipping the potions
uh again if you're a little bit tired of
this you can just skip this episode the
next one we'll be doing some different
stuff uh but I thought it'd be a little
more detrimental to be cutting my
progress because you'd be a little
confused on what happened and again it's
not super true to what flipping nature
is really so yeah enough of intro we're
going to start at about 7.3 mil and yeah
we'll see where we can get today
okay so first up here we're going to do
the energy potion um looked like it has
about 26 GP margin on it after
calculations and everything we're buying
it for the high price so we should buy
these pretty quickly if not instantly
let's have a quick look here okay we
didn't buy any so we will come back with
a second item then and next up we're
going to do the super strength potion um
this one actually had 137 GP margin on
it it's definitely a more expensive item
for sure but still definitely worth
doing these are really popular obviously
for pking almost anything um so yeah
we'll buy them for the low price which
is $475 and uh we should give 137k on
each one I don't think we can afford the
Capo so we'll just buy a th000 and uh
that should net us about 140k which is
pretty good and last step here we're
going to do the anti- poison again this
thing has a 200 GP margin if I buy it
for the high price you can see why I'm
having a problem giving up these potions
they're just so good so we're plopping
this in for the high price yeah none of
them bought but still I mean I should
get some of these and it will be good
amount profit so we will check back in a
couple hours when these are
bought okay so we're still waiting on
the anti-poison but the strength potion
and the energy potions have all sold so
we'll just calculate what we made on
those quickly uh so the strength potion
we got 106 GP margin after calculations
and we got about a th000 of those giving
us about 106k which is pretty nice uh
the energy potions we got 24 GP margin
on and 2K of those giving us 48k so
pretty standard nothing too exciting but
also completely steady progress which is
nice so we'll probably just toss the
anti-poison in at a lower price uh but
we'll find a couple more items to start
first okay so coming up here we got a
totally brand new item jokes it's a
super anti-poison uh it looks like it
has actually like a 300 GP margin on it
so it can't not do it it's so hard uh
but these are just working so well maybe
I'll just have to get a really popular
video to ruin this method so I can move
on to something else
uh but yeah has a 300 GP margin on it so
we're going to buy 2,000 of those why
wouldn't we and we'll get one other item
at least going on
here and the magic potion has a 66 GP
margin on it as well I'm not making this
stuff up guys just go check it I mean
seriously just do it it's so easy to do
I'm making loads of money doing it I've
been doing this for almost a week now
look magic potions instantly bought for
the high price but either way that's
still leaving us with 66 GP margin on
each one
which when we get 2,000 of those that is
133k the magic potions themselves are
super cheap like that only cost me I
wonder if we can open the history again
um yeah only cost me 774k and I'm
getting 133 back and keep in mind we are
instantly buying the item so again just
go do it so it ruins it and then I can
move on to something else um so yeah
we'll plop it in for 605 and we'll get
one more item going and lastly here
we're going to do the ranging potion I I
can see my history there I mean it's
just literally the next potion I tried
I'm not even thinking about this too
much I'm just kind of popping in potions
and they almost all have profit for them
so this one we're going to get about a
100 to 150 GP profit on I think we can
only afford a th000 of them definitely
can't afford 1,500 uh closer to 1,000 so
we'll plop it in there for
2.1k and we will come back when some of
the stuff have bought and
sold so everything has sold including
anti poisons everything in total so we
will do a calculation of everything here
we did pretty well for ourselves on this
flip even though it was just the potions
again so we will collect all these and
we'll start going down what we made so
to start with we will do the super anti
poisons so on those we got 144 GP margin
and we did buy all 2,000 of those that's
288k which is really nice um next the
magic potions we got a 6 six GP margin
on and again we bought all 2,000 of
those we have the history open here so
you might be able to see but maybe not
but anyway the magic potions we got
131k the anti poisons we got the 150 GP
margin on as well uh and again we got
all 2,000 of those and we got 300K from
the anti poisons the ranging potions we
got
27 um Marg GP margin on it but uh we
only got 177 of those so that's only 26k
so we did very well uh it's all over 750
K from that flip um and yeah so we'll
get some new items going so first up
here we're going to do the magic potion
it has a 40gp margin and it is such a
cheap item that's very good actually so
we'll buy 2,000 of these for the low
price of about 380 GP and we'll get a
couple more items going so the range
potion had a 115 GP margin on it which
is pretty good as well um so we'll go
buy a couple thousand of those uh which
should hopefully net us 200k uh we'll
buy them for two 2.2k sorry and um we'll
probably get at least one more
item next up will be the energy potion
another very good item if you are low on
cash but still want to do some very very
lucrative flips um so we'll buy them for
332 coins only and we'll get 2K of those
and we'll get one more item as
well and lastly here we're going to do
the anti- poison again this item still
has even among the realm of Po ions that
I've overdone this one is still probably
one of the best has about 200 GP margin
and it's a very cheap item so we'll come
back uh when everything has
sold so the flips have all sold and uh
we did pretty well for ourselves again
here uh so on the anti poisons we got
823 we managed to buy uh giving us a 125
GP margin um which gives us about
103k so pretty decent the ranging
potions we only got uh 37 of them
um and at 135 GP margin we got about 5k
so not so good on that one uh the energy
potions we got a 66 GP margin and we got
all 2,000 of them so that's 132k and the
magic potion same thing we got all 2,000
of them uh but about half the margin so
we got 65k so pretty good pretty
standard but we probably made another
300K uh so yeah let's do a couple more
of
these so for our first new item in quite
a while we're going to do the Ring of
wealth um this is actually done at the
recommendation of one of my viewers um
so we'll try this item out it has about
a 500 GP margin on it which is pretty
decent for the price it is um but we'll
give a shot so we'll put it in for
30.1k and uh we'll see how many we can
buy here we'll get maybe 250 maybe not
that many uh we'll go for 200 and we'll
try to find one extra item as well okay
so we're going to do the energy potion
uh it has about a 30 40 GP margin on it
which is pretty standard for the item
very common um which is still really
nice that's about 60 to 70k will make on
it uh so we'll buy a couple thousand of
these okay and next up we are going to
do the Redwood logs um it only said 25
GP margin on it but um it's definitely
lower than it normally is although I
checked the graphs and they seem to be
crashing slowly and slowly but we'll
give it a try um I flipped these once
before and they worked decently well uh
so we'll put it in for 12275 and we'll
buy a, of these or something or
1,200 and um make sure I have the right
price in here what am I doing
no no no no put the price back put the
price back what am I okay we almost
goofed that up a bit let's check here
okay so 1275 is the Buy price so we'll
go do that again I don't know why I'm
freaking myself out these clips are
recorded a little while ago but I still
don't understand what I'm doing so we'll
put it in for 1275 and uh do, 1500 of
them okay so all the flips are in and uh
we are moderately successful on all of
them the rings of wealth we got about a
300 GP margin on but I would like to try
them again cuz they did buy and sell
pretty quickly and even that we're still
going to make a decent amount of money
from them um but yeah so the rings of
wealth got actually 280 on each one and
200 Rings that's 56k from the Rings uh
the energy potions unfortunately I think
we got the most from again uh so we got
52 on each potion and 2,000 of those
makes about
103k and the Redwood logs we got about
25 on each about 1,500 logs gives us
about 36k so about 200k in total so not
unhappy with the flip but um we're still
kind of experimenting with items trying
to find some that will beat the potion
so let's go try a couple new
items I tried so hard to find a new item
but I just could not find one with a
decent margin and these still have a 40
GP margin on it we're going to be gone
for a couple days so we're going to buy
6K of
these uh and we'll try to find something
new I promise but it's I'm yeah well
let's give it another
try Okay so something weird happened
here um we thought we messed up again so
we put the the rings of wealth in for
29705 and we hit confirm and then they
instab buy which is weird so I obviously
I thought I just put it for the wrong
price but I look here and I definitely
did not um so if this ends up being a
flop it's not 100% my fault um because
we put it in for yeah the low price
29705 and the insta bot so we have to
check out see look at that oh I see what
I did okay so what happened is I bought
the wrong rings I bought the Ring of
wealth
uncharged oh my god I think I'm
cursed so I guess we'll have to go sell
these off at probably a loss so whatever
we'll go dump these in for whatever
their low price is and we'll find
something else okay so we're going to do
a bit of a throwback we're going to do
the Rune arrows again um just cuz I
don't want to pick a
potion I'm fighting to not do it so
we'll buy them for 120 coins each and
we'll get the maxed out buying limit of
11,000 nope
10K all right so we'll come back when
this stuff is
sold okay so we are actually able to
sell the rings of wealth with only a one
GP loss which I count is a win that is
pretty good um see look we bought him
for $
27996 and we sold them for $
27995 so I think that should be counted
as a win we didn't suffer any losses
from another mistake so that is you
learn Le from your mistakes and if they
don't cost anything that is the best
kind of mistake okay so we only lost 200
GP from uh the Rings and we got 74 GP
margin on the energy potions giving us
about 50k so overall could have been
much worse so we're not giving up we
will try the Rings again but first up we
are going to put some potions in of
course um so we'll put them in this had
about a 50 GP margin on it so we'll do
another 2,000 of those if you're
wondering why I take a couple off it's
just because um if you hit the buying
limit exactly you can't check the margin
again which is a bit of a pain um so
yeah we'll put it a little bit less than
2,000 and find something else okay so
next we're going to do the super defense
again uh this item has worked out quite
well if you have about four or five mil
to buy with this has about 15 GP margin
giving us about 300K assuming we buy
these all and uh we get at least one
more item going as well and surprisingly
the regular strength potion actually has
a really huge margin on it I think it's
like 200 GP uh which is a little odd so
we're going to try this item out it is a
new item but not not
really so I think we're actually going
to fill up the top slot here so we'll do
one more item and lastly here we're
going to have just enough for one more
potion we'll do the super anti- poison
um can't afford this many we'll have to
do like 1,800 but it had about 150 GP
margin on it so I think we're going to
make pretty decent amount on this flip
but uh we'll come back and know for
sure so the flips are in and uh we have
bought pretty much everything that we
wanted and sold it all so this is a
pretty full flip which is nice um so
we'll start with the let's start with
the worst flip the worst flip is the
energy potions uh we got 23 GP margin on
those but we did get all 2,000 uh so
about 45k from those and next best was
the strength potion which we got a 35 GP
margin on still got all 2,000 it's at
75k and next the super defense we got
only 58 GP margin on unfortunately but
we still did get 2K of them that's 116k
from that and the super anti poisons
were the best we got 133 on each one and
we got nearly 2,000 so about 240k from
that really good flip we got about 500k
from that and uh we'll do a couple more
of these we'll try to get up to the 10
mil Mark maybe and then we'll end the
episode okay so first up will be the
strength potion three uh we'll do a
couple thousand of these again about 30
40 GP margin on it so pretty decent next
up we'll do the energy potion again had
about a 30 40gp margin on it so it's
pretty decent we're doing 4,000 5,000
6,000 uh because we're going to go to
bed pretty soon so we'll try buy more of
these overnight at least and lastly here
we're going to do the Ring of wealth
which actually has about a 2K margin on
it which right now which is really good
um so we'll go ahead and do this item as
the last one so we totally locked out on
this one um the rings of wealth Rose by
like 5K and I managed to sell them for
that uh but 40 37k Sor so that's insane
amount of profit from that one so we'll
go ahead and go through the other items
first so the energy potions we actually
only broke even on which are a little
annoying but I'm not too disappointed
because of the Rings of wealth uh the
strength potions we did get all 4K of
those and a 32 GP margin gave us about
130k in profit but look at the rings of
wealth they Rose by like 5K overnight we
uh sold them for about 6K profit each
and got 150 rings that
865k in profit I wish we'd bought more
but look at that we're in the green
stack we got 10 mil and we're on day
three so we are doing very well for
ourselves we can hopefully get up to 11
12 mil before we have to renew our bond
um but yeah thanks for watching guys I
promise going forward we are not going
to do as many potions I will still do
them but it's not going to be the main
focus of the episode so thanks for
tuning in guys uh if you enjoyed just
hit that subscribe button and I will see
you guys in in episode 8
[Music]